Julie Stout: Okay, I'm here with Inta Carpenter once again for part 3 of our interview. My name is Julie Sout, and it is March 6, 2026.
Julie Stout: And we are here in Bloomington, Indiana, to continue the last part of our interview, which is specifically about folklorist Richard Dawson. And thank you for being with me once again, and if… unless you have any questions, I can move right to that first question. Okay.
Julie Stout: So, first encounters with Dawson. I know you recounted a little bit of this in our very first interview, in terms of the program and everything, but would you be able to recount that for me? For when and how did you first meet Dawson, and what were your earliest impressions?
Julie Stout: Well, I first met him, actually.
Julie Stout: Or second, that was… Oh, before that incident. No, that must have been second. That had to be second. But I…
Julie Stout: It had to be second.
Julie Stout: I met in… I had applied to the folklore department. I had just had a child, and I wanted to,
Julie Stout: Get back to school for a little while.
Julie Stout: And my husband brought home the idea that I take a degree in folklore.
Julie Stout: because I had been a child welfare worker in Colorado, and we planned to return, and that folklore might be a good
Julie Stout: Skill to have.
Julie Stout: If… when I took back the… the job in, social, social…
Julie Stout: What? Social work? Social work.
Julie Stout: So, I had applied in the… in the spring, I would imagine.
Julie Stout: And the summer passes, and fall comes, and I think, well, wait a minute, I haven't been… I haven't received an admission letter. Have I not been… have not been notified that I haven't been admitted? And so I went over to the department.
Julie Stout: And they sent the… the secretaries downstairs sent me upstairs to talk to Dawson about this.
Julie Stout: He happened to be in the office. I went in, I saw a man behind a desk that was
Julie Stout: just com…
Julie Stout: tumbled with pieces of paper. The floor was tumbled with pieces of paper and magazines and everything else, and I guess that was kind of my first introduction to graduate school, frankly.
Julie Stout: I hadn't really been on the university campus very much. My husband was studying for a master's degree, and I was still at home.
Julie Stout: So… he said.
Julie Stout: that, yes, that I had applied. He found the application. Nothing had been done about it. People had lost track of the thing. He knew for no reason whatsoever. And,
Julie Stout: I was admitted.
Julie Stout: That was it. Right then and there. Right then and there.
Julie Stout: Classes started, I think, pretty much the next day.
Julie Stout: What was, your impression of him, besides the, the paper strewn everywhere in his office? Were you able to get a good gauge on him?
Julie Stout: I don't know, he was a… he struck me as an absent-minded professor. I didn't know anything of… of his,
Julie Stout: Reputation. I knew nothing. I knew what he looked like.
Julie Stout: I had just seen what he looked like, and
Julie Stout: And I guess the fact that made me think of the stereotype of an absent-minded professor was the look of the… of the… of the office, and the fact that the chair of the department would… would miss an application, that seemed like
Julie Stout: What's… what's this all about?
Julie Stout: How to get lost to begin with. Yeah, how to get lost to begin with.
Julie Stout: So that was it. I don't…
Julie Stout: I… I… the next time I actually saw him, because I wasn't taking a class, I don't think, from him.
Julie Stout: I don't know.
Julie Stout: was in a line to vote, so that would be in November, and we were… we were standing in the same voting line.
Julie Stout: And we ended up talking to him.
Julie Stout: Maybe I was taking a class, I don't know.
Julie Stout: Because shortly after that, he got in touch with me and offered me, An editorial assistantship.
Julie Stout: And he was working at that point on…
Julie Stout: Possibly folklore told around the world.
Julie Stout: But I'd have to look at his… at his books to be sure.
Julie Stout: So I ended up editing that.
Julie Stout: And this was 72. The Land of the Millrats? What? The Land of the Millrats was 72?
Julie Stout: No. Oh, no, I'm so sorry. No, this would be much later. Around the world. And these had… I think it was…
Julie Stout: I think it was around the folklore told around the world, because it was a big book, from different countries, from different countries. And he had done the series of folktales told around the world. I'd have to look at his books.
Julie Stout: So I worked in that position with him for 2 years.
Julie Stout: two years, yeah, from 72 to 75, and then the next job was the Gary project. Was the coordinator. And I think he started another book in those years, and I was the research assistant, so he would ask for specific things that he wanted done, and then once it was done, I liked editing, and…
Julie Stout: I would do the editing, too.
Julie Stout: Before it was sent to the…
Julie Stout: Or publisher. And that was after the coordinator position? The research assistant editing position?
Julie Stout: So you're the editorial assistant first.
Julie Stout: And then you moved into coordinator, and then you were his research assistant, or was research assistant in tandem? It was the one book… the book that I started doing was… it needed editing, and the next book needed research. So, I think that some of that was started with the Gary project, and then, as I said, the Gary project wasn't full.
Julie Stout: full term, and I was still working on other things for him. So it was in the same time period.
Julie Stout: What did you… what would you… what was your relationship to him after the Gary project?
Julie Stout: After the Gary project? Well, I knew him somewhat better. I knew him better. It was collegial, I think, would be probably the… Were you still working for him in any capacity?
Julie Stout: What? Were you still working for him? Oh, yeah, yeah, definitely. At some point, he decided… I don't know what prompted it, I've forgotten now what prompted it.
Julie Stout: he has a…
Julie Stout: Whether it was discussed with the department or he did it as a chair, he divided up
Julie Stout: what had been the Folklore Institute into the Folklore Department and the Folklore Institute.
Julie Stout: And… he and I and the… and the assistants, the folklore assistants.
Julie Stout: for the Institute, Folklore Institute.
Julie Stout: Started working on a lot of projects.
Julie Stout: So, the books, his books, but then conferences that would come by that were going to be done at the department, and we had our own secretary, whom I was still in touch with. I was just with her a couple days ago.
Julie Stout: So, that… and the… we mostly started new projects with the faculty, to some extent, with Linda Daig, particularly.
Julie Stout: And some others, but… but the conf… the folklore department was always coming up with… with… with conferences, and so it was good that they… that there was some…
Julie Stout: Focus.
Julie Stout: To that. So we… the conferences were done maybe a little bit with more help than it had before.
Julie Stout: Can you remind me if that is when you were… project coordinator was full-time position?
Julie Stout: Is… am I remembering that correctly? I think so. So then, after the project, the Gary project ended, you were in another full-time position helping out and everything with the conferences and other… Yeah, something brought money. I think Dawson started looking for money for me that
Julie Stout: Was, first of all, grant money.
Julie Stout: And then he was able to…
Julie Stout: turn it into a full-time faculty, not a faculty, it was… it was faculty.
Julie Stout: Bauman did that. It was a…
Julie Stout: a full-time job, and it was funded by the university, but I don't remember exactly when that happened.
Julie Stout: 75… by 77 or so, maybe? 8, 78, it had happened.
Julie Stout: He died in 83.
Julie Stout: And by then, I had a full university job.
Julie Stout: And then Dick Bauman that job into… A faculty job.
Julie Stout: a faculty job, but it was a research faculty job, which was kind of odd, too. Which you took on? You took that off? The research faculty job?
Julie Stout: That one just changed the source of where the money came from. I see.
Julie Stout: That meant that I could apply for the same kind of,
Julie Stout: grants that faculty could. I could teach if I wanted to, and I did do some teaching, yeah, once I got interested in applied folklore.
Julie Stout: I talk.
Julie Stout: with, usually with someone. I think I did one class of my own on applied folklore.
Julie Stout: I just talked to one of the students from that yesterday.
Julie Stout: Just gonna visit here. Yeah.
Julie Stout: That's awesome, actually.
Julie Stout: Because I know that you mentioned in our first interview the… How much you…
Julie Stout: I believe applied folklore and public folklore is…
Julie Stout: a great way to incorporate folklore in terms of impacting people, so I love that you still have contact with one of your students. With some of the students who like to do that, too. Yeah, one visited me earlier this year around AFS. She went to AFS and then came to Bloomington to see all her,
Julie Stout: her… faculty. She talked to Henry and John McDowell, and me, and somebody else, I don't remember.
Julie Stout: Do you remember her name?
Julie Stout: I did, till you asked me. Okay, no worries.
Julie Stout: Okay, so because you've worked with Dawson for a number of years, I'm curious to know how you would describe Dawson's approach to research
Julie Stout: supervision, and collaboration. To research supervision. Oh, how would you describe Dawson's approach to research, supervision, and collaboration? Oh. Yes.
Julie Stout: Whether that be the way that he prepares things, how he gives feedback, or… I think for me, it was pretty light-handed, because he…
Julie Stout: He liked the way I edited.
Julie Stout: Some of the people I edited did not, sometimes, because he hated the passive word, and I hate the passive word as well. But a lot of academics use the passive, because it's… do you?
Julie Stout: I use it. Not knowingly. Not knowingly. It's just the way my brain works.
Julie Stout: So he let that be, and I know that, oh, gosh.
Julie Stout: Where's names… names go.
Julie Stout: There was a… A good friend of his was a very influential folklorist from California, from Berkeley.
Julie Stout: Dundas. Dundas. Richard Dundas. And boy, did he not like my taking out the passive word. Was he at the around the same time as Dawson?
Julie Stout: Well, he was in California at the same time. Yeah, they were buddies. They were really good friends.
Julie Stout: Students still read his articles today, along with Dawson's, and along with Bauman's. Those are, like, the… oh, and Orang's articles. And Orang's, yeah. His are the best written, I think. The Trinity of… He'll be… he would be happy to hear that.
Julie Stout: He should have been a faculty member here, but… Anyway.
Julie Stout: So, where were we? So, I think he knew I was going to do my work, so supervision, I say it was more colleague than anything else, and we pretty much agreed on
Julie Stout: On how we read folklore, except for the… the public and the… and the,
Julie Stout: they applied. And I think, for me, it was always more… I was… I'm more interested in applied folklore than public folklore.
Julie Stout: To some extent, I agreed with him. He said that public folklore was like a big, happy birthday party. I think he actually put that in to some article that he wrote, and he and I wrote an article together with our different… with our two points of view.
Julie Stout: And there was some public… a person from Appalachia at that point that
Julie Stout: That, Dawson invited to campus.
Julie Stout: God, I wish I could remember his name.
Julie Stout: And he really understood applied folklore. He really did, because he was… he was bringing forth the… the songs of the people and the stories of the people into books that he did. Gosh.
Julie Stout: I can't remember his name, from Kentucky. So I think that's probably my answer to your question. Okay.
Julie Stout: You said that he was… he came off as more of an absent-minded professor when you first met him.
Julie Stout: As you got to know him, what traits best captured Dawson as a person, would you say?
Julie Stout: Which is… this is all from your perspective, so… Yeah, I tried to find the… the…
Julie Stout: the comments that I read at the memorial service for him here. I'll still try to find them, but my…
Julie Stout: My archives, personally, are a mess, and and it… anyway, it's not important.
Julie Stout: But I think I, I said in that, that…
Julie Stout: to some extent, he was haunted by… by his education. He went to a very elite,
Julie Stout: undergraduate, or high school? What is that called? Anyway, he was…
Julie Stout: what was it? I don't even know what that was called, but it was… it was one of the ones that only elite people end up in, and his family was…
Julie Stout: What? Like, a preparatory school, like, for college? Yeah, right. Okay. Right.
Julie Stout: Or, like, a boarding school? Boarding school, right. His family was quite wealthy, so they… they were able to, do that. He had brothers and sisters, I think.
Julie Stout: I know I met his sister one time. Oh, after he died.
Julie Stout: And from there, he went to Harvard.
Julie Stout: And he went very quickly. He was very young. He was very young when he landed in Harvard. He went right away from boarding school.
Julie Stout: And there, he met all kinds of people who were famous. He was not so famous, he was just there with them. And he knew them, and we would all recognize the names of these people that he was there with as a student. And I think that he brought a lot of that
Julie Stout: kind of… Wishing that he could do something similar himself to Bloomington.
Julie Stout: So… The fact that he turned what…
Julie Stout: Stith Thompson had in the English department into an independent department is not surprising at all.
Julie Stout: Because I think, to some extent, he was… he was very ambitious about what he himself could accomplish.
Julie Stout: And possessive about that.
Julie Stout: ambitious, and… he wanted acknowledgement for his work, essentially?
Julie Stout: How would you describe him, like, personally?
Julie Stout: Besides those two things. Well, I mean…
Julie Stout: all over the place, really, all over the place. He had a sense of humor when he was in the mood. He liked to write about himself and kind of make fun of himself with the pajamas and various other things that happened to him in AFS, and he would write about it and laugh.
Julie Stout: At himself.
Julie Stout: But only if he chose to do that.
Julie Stout: And there were students, definitely, that he did not particularly support, which was too bad.
Julie Stout: Do you know for what reason?
Julie Stout: they were… they were just approaching folklore in a way that wasn't his way, I suppose.
Julie Stout: I don't know how, how… Public full time?
Julie Stout: Well, that eventually, yeah, yeah, he definitely…
Julie Stout: Did not help that go forward very much, but he also died in 83, so some of this,
Julie Stout: was irrelevant.
Julie Stout: But I know that there were… there are definitely students who… who did not do well with him and had no good feelings about him. That's absolutely true. I can say the same for faculty, that faculty
Julie Stout: At that time were also treated differently, depending upon whatever it was he imagined.
Julie Stout: Or didn't like about the way that they did.
Julie Stout: That included Linda Daig.
Julie Stout: He would actually… How did that work?
Julie Stout: I remember one time he told me that he had
Julie Stout: He had seen that Linda Dagg was going to come in the door to that party, and he went out the back door. So, I mean, that kind of stuff.
Julie Stout: So that he didn't agree with their methodology. Although, when he… yeah, when he brought her here, he thought she was terrific. He was the one who hired her here, and fought for her to be able to get, you know, a good position.
Julie Stout: So, I don't know what happened there.
Julie Stout: But that could happen with him, definitely. You could get on his wrong side, and then you were in trouble.
Julie Stout: Due to, the way you said people conduct their work as a methodology, or,
Julie Stout: just… whatever. Pretty much, pretty much whatever, I would think, and he would, he would choose sides occasionally, which really annoyed me.
Julie Stout: As to which…
Julie Stout: Which person got more support, maybe, than they deserved, and someone else who did not get the kind of support that they deserved.
Julie Stout: So, I occasionally got involved with some students that way, just trying to I don't know. Mediate?
Julie Stout: not entirely mediate as to just inform, and I don't know that that was at all the right thing to do, but… but I… I didn't want to see…
Julie Stout: I just didn't want to see people… I don't know.
Julie Stout: I don't know. How do you think he would view the department today? The folklore department today? How would he do the department today? How would he view…
Julie Stout: Whether it be the people, the current faculty… I don't know them today, so I can't really answer that question.
Julie Stout: I could have answered it in 2010, but…
Julie Stout: I'm not that involved with the department at all. As much anymore? I know they leave good impressions, very good impressions, but I don't know their particular work. Hiller, I know more personally.
Julie Stout: And we share an interest in public and applied folklore, so that makes it…
Julie Stout: Definitely easy, but the ethomusicology people, I don't know. I get a good impression of McDonald. I think his work is fascinating.
Julie Stout: But I don't… I don't really know them. I knew Ruth Stone, and that was probably… and I know Dick Bauman and Beverly, and…
Julie Stout: And he brought them here, so Dawson did. No, he didn't. He wanted to, and then didn't. He instead saved…
Julie Stout: Or… or… he did something for ethnomusicology when he was gonna bring Dawson here,
Julie Stout: Bauman here. And then he put that aside, and then the department brought him later, after Henry had been brought here.
Julie Stout: So he was… he was good buddies with Henry.
Julie Stout: Boom.
Julie Stout: And you're glossy?
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: I, I don't know, I think that he would, he would respect some, for sure.
Julie Stout: Brandon? Brandon Barker? I would think.
Julie Stout: He does good work, from what I've seen.
Julie Stout: That's… that's about all I know is him.
Julie Stout: It's a new generation of faculty, so I do not blame you for not remembering all of them off the top of your head. That was just a curious question I had for that.
Julie Stout: So, we discussed a bit in the last interview about your collaboration with Dorsen, and you also discussed your… what you worked on with him and for him.
Julie Stout: Can you describe a situation where you or others collaborated with Dawson, and how was it handled, and what did you take from that experience?
Julie Stout: Let me know if you want me to repeat that.
Julie Stout: Well…
Julie Stout: I was better friends with Linda Dagg. No.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Julie Stout: In fact, we were in a… in a castle in Hungary.
Julie Stout: Together.
Julie Stout: Stayed the night. It was fun.
Julie Stout: Yeah, weird one.
Julie Stout: What would be a… the conferences, I suppose the conferences would be it.
Julie Stout: Did you learn anything from your experiences collaborating with him?
Julie Stout: We're working with him.
Julie Stout: we got along. We got along just fine. It was,
Julie Stout: What did… what could I have learned? I mean, he certainly was passionate about folklore. Absolutely passionate about folklore.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Julie Stout: I can't say the same for me. I got passionate when he probably wouldn't have wanted to, which was when the class came in who was all interested in public folklore and applied folklore. It was a large class, and
Julie Stout: And,
Julie Stout: that made me feel alive, and that's… that's partly how Traditional Arts Indiana came about, was from the experience with those students, and also with… with, Sandy Dalby, because she and I ran a class
Julie Stout: With the students at her house, and we would just talk simply, informally about… and maybe read, read some things, and then talk about, applied folklore and public folklore.
Julie Stout: So… I…
Julie Stout: I really was not passionate about… about folklore, as… as fairy tales and folktales and legends and…
Julie Stout: I… if you asked me questions, I wouldn't be able to answer very many of them at all. I got into personal experience stories, and that's how I wrote my dissertation, so… and as you know, it was very delayed. I didn't finish it until… I don't even remember.
Julie Stout: 89, maybe? Something like that.
Julie Stout: and then had the… the freedom at the department to do my own work with the Latvians, so it was pretty incredible. When the conference came around, I would… I would work with that, and I worked with… with the journal. I worked with Mary Doll…
Julie Stout: Right.
Julie Stout: Mary Ellen… Mary… Why can't I say it?
Julie Stout: Mary Ellen, Mary Ellen Brown, Mary Ellen Brown, on the Journal of Folklore Research for years, and we really became friends doing that.
Julie Stout: So… he… he opened up a career for me, which was… Which was wonderful.
Julie Stout: The students… the students have been… they've been… they've been the jewels in the crown, as far as I'm concerned, in the department.
Julie Stout: he was such a strong, I don't want to say dictator exactly, but pretty close. He was so strong in his own ideas as a chair that he really did silence the other,
Julie Stout: The other faculty, and that was unfortunate.
Julie Stout: And they learn to… I think they learned to be that way, so the faculty have never been particularly outspoken, I think, until now.
Julie Stout: Really? Now, maybe the younger generation, I remember one of the chairs once saying to me, they just sit there like bumps on a log, you know, and when it's over, they leave, and nobody gets involved. Yeah.
Julie Stout: I don't know how much of that is true anymore, I don't know. Yeah. But I get the feeling that these are more spoken-up people.
Julie Stout: The generational difference, yeah, yeah. It's something to think about as well. Which is kind of what sparked my question of.
Julie Stout: How would Dawson react to the department today? I'd be curious to know who he would be.
Julie Stout: intrigued by, or maybe… Not wanting to work as closely with, or something like that.
Julie Stout: He would respect whoever he really thought was very, very good at the job. Good at what they did. And good at what they did. Yeah. And, I mean, that makes me think about…
Julie Stout: The people who have been productive, but also who… who have a personality that's… that's open.
Julie Stout: He liked people. You sometimes never know that, but he really did like people, and he loved going out in the field.
Julie Stout: And meeting people.
Julie Stout: So I think for… there are a number of people in the department, and he'd be glad that Henry was still there. He respects Bauman, without doubt.
Julie Stout: They're all gone.
Julie Stout: McDowell?
Julie Stout: Yeah. Yeah. From the older.
Julie Stout: And I know Henry and McDonald also go to events and everything, and, stuff like that, so… there's a…
Julie Stout: legacy there that's still being imparted onto, like, junior faculty, I think, as well. From Henry. Yeah, exactly.
Julie Stout: Oops.
Julie Stout: No, I've got to call him back later.
Julie Stout: I'll just let it be.
Julie Stout: Okay.
Julie Stout: So, we talked quite a bit about the Dorsey & Gary project, so I'm gonna move on to the next question, if that's okay? Are there any specific anecdotes, positive, difficult, or complex, that illustrate what he was like to work with?
Julie Stout: anecdote. Yeah.
Julie Stout: Oh gosh, I should have prepared for that one, I didn't.
Julie Stout: Actually, we can come back to it at a different time, if that is better for you.
Julie Stout: We went… we went to lunch, we would talk… we would… we would leave the office and go for lunch, and
Julie Stout: Which was good, to just…
Julie Stout: to just talk… I don't know, just easy. He was easy for me to talk to.
Julie Stout: And I suppose we laughed.
Julie Stout: Sometime? I don't know.
Julie Stout: No, I… I don't know. I really… Anecdote.
Julie Stout: I don't know. Even if I think a long time, I may not come up with anything. That's definitely okay. Okay. We can move to the next one, too. If I do, I will let you know. Just let me know.
Julie Stout: This is my final question, so we've reached the end, but…
Julie Stout: How has your view of Dawson's contributions
Julie Stout: Or con… and… and or controversies.
Julie Stout: evolved over time.
Julie Stout: So that's a part one of my question.
Julie Stout: How has your view of Dawson's contributions and controversies evolved over time? Well, my feeling is that he sort of disappeared from the department, so his contribution is minimal at best, because the
Julie Stout: The conference… the, the, the lecture.
Julie Stout: The Dawson Lecture in no way particularly brings his
Julie Stout: Whatever his contribution could be to the foreground in any particular way, except that they're… the lecturers are folklorists, usually.
Julie Stout: Boom.
Julie Stout: So, I don't really think that…
Julie Stout: I'm surprised he's red anymore. I don't… I don't… I wouldn't know.
Julie Stout: And whether it'd be interesting to me whether… I mean, academics suffer in that way, it seems to me, that… that…
Julie Stout: The theory comes and goes.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: Dawson didn't have that much theory, but I think he did really… he was a very good writer. He was a good writer. And he… he did…
Julie Stout: I think that blood… What was that called? Blood.
Julie Stout: Stoppers and Blood Bear… and Bear Walkers. It was a really good book.
Julie Stout: But I doubt very much that it's being taught anymore. I could be wrong, but…
Julie Stout: And the people that he wrote… he wrote books about, or he… he… he ordered books from, to write anthologies, they're… they're gone, too. So everything's sort of, like, from the past now.
Julie Stout: I think that happens with most academics in some way.
Julie Stout: think about Del Himes now was so important, a person for… for writing papers back when I was in school, and…
Julie Stout: I don't think he is anymore.
Julie Stout: We did have to read a few articles for classes.
Julie Stout: But I think you're right in that… when we…
Julie Stout: Cover theory in graduate-level folklore classes.
Julie Stout: it is Elliot, Orring, Bauman, and Dundees who are the main three that I would say
Julie Stout: Rote on theory, and are able to…
Julie Stout: their works are still able to be taught in classes today. Other examples of, like, field work that was done is taught in the capacity of, this is an example of fieldwork you can do, and so the extent of how these can be brought into the classroom
Julie Stout: differs depending on who's teaching it. I think that's right. Yeah. I think that's right. Those are the three. Yeah. I would say.
Julie Stout: And I'm living proof of that.
Julie Stout: So, my part two of that final question is, what should students and future researchers understand about his impact and the complexities of his legacy?
Julie Stout: What would you like people to know? Students? Well, the dedication to the discipline that he… he did create a department. I think his…
Julie Stout: His seeing that if he increased the size, he increased the… what the folklore department represented by adding ethomusicology.
Julie Stout: Would be helpful. He did it, as I told you. He… he delayed
Julie Stout: hiring Dick Bauman for that, and we really needed him at that point, Dick Bauman, and it was a disappointment when he didn't come until later.
Julie Stout: So, his dedication to folklore is… should be recognized more than it is, what it takes in a university to hold on to a small department, and to keep the…
Julie Stout: To keep the legacy of, of…
Julie Stout: Stith Thompson, even, you know, that this… that it would be one of those departments that they call Jewel of the Crown, or whatever.
Julie Stout: And they just recently did that at the lecture of Dory Noyes, you know, that the dean who was there used that exact phrase, kind of like to protect folklore, and…
Julie Stout: Dawson certainly fought for it.
Julie Stout: He fought for folklore and university.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: He did, he was… And it's placed within the university. Yeah, he was, you know, he was looking for money for them all the time. He tried to support the students as much as he could.
Julie Stout: He brought people here that he thought were… would be good, but he didn't get much of that. I mean, 83 was…
Julie Stout: Was, still… When did he create the department?
Julie Stout: When did he create the department?
Julie Stout: I don't know. That's okay.
Julie Stout: That's okay.
Julie Stout: I'm just trying to think, probably in the 50s or late 40s, or… Is that possible?
Julie Stout: Or later than that.
Julie Stout: I don't know.
Julie Stout: I mean, I came in in 70, and… Was it 57?
Julie Stout: I'm trying to remember. Maybe. Well, they're celebrating 100. Yeah. That's right, they're celebrating 100, so it would be…
Julie Stout: But that was… they're going to… with the Stiff Thompson thing then.
Julie Stout: 1925.
Julie Stout: 1926.
Julie Stout: 2026.
Julie Stout: This is the year. So they're going with Stat Thompson, they're not going with… Officially, yes, yeah. Yeah. Because he was the one who also brought the collection over as well. The Folklore collection.
Julie Stout: I believe.
Julie Stout: when Moira Marsh, who is the folklore librarian at IU, was speaking to us.
Julie Stout: That is when she mentioned that as well.
Julie Stout: But Dawson, of course, gets…
Julie Stout: immense credit for the Folklore Institute and the department and everything like that.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Well, I think that Dawson… Dawson was a harder grader. I don't think he… he… he… His standards were quite high? He… his standards were quite high, that's right, and
Julie Stout: We're talking too long. Oh, no, you're good.
Julie Stout: Yeah, they're, you know, they're…
Julie Stout: Henry gives a lot of A's, just because he doesn't think that the grades are important, and…
Julie Stout: He just puts them away, and…
Julie Stout: So, it just says, thank you for writing it, and I think your hardest one of your three would probably be Elliot Oring. He's not going to give you very good grades unless you earn them, without a doubt.
Julie Stout: professors and their… Yeah, some of this should probably be erased.
Julie Stout: you had a few notes that you wrote down before this, and I would love to give you the floor and an opportunity to share anything that came to mind for you as you were preparing for this, and…
Julie Stout: And your graciousness in letting me ask you these questions to begin with.
Julie Stout: So I give you the floor for whatever you want. Okay, thank you. Yeah.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Okay.
Julie Stout: Yeah, this maybe is not gonna… working within culture, Croatian. Milan Opacic, yeah, he's gotta come up, I would hope, somewhere. Milan Opicic. Milan Opacic, Tomborica.
Julie Stout: And an instrument maker.
Julie Stout: He… he… there's… there was a good amount of material created by him.
Julie Stout: Jenny's Cafe, the owner.
Julie Stout: Also claimed… claimed by Serbs.
Julie Stout: So the Serbs and Croatians were…
Julie Stout: Oh, I write down here, Dawson's comments, often cited in student articles. So there must have been some of those that were either funny or became things that they said.
Julie Stout: Guzla, the Serbs, the Guzla from… for the epic songs.
Julie Stout: Oh, young people. Oh, I wanted to look up the… the Gary Croatian Tombarica group.
Julie Stout: and other of the music groups from them. I wondered if any of them still survived.
Julie Stout: And there's something called a root chich restaurant, Or the… Pre-Radovich Club.
Julie Stout: That… whether it's still going on.
Julie Stout: That's probably not.
Julie Stout: Oh, and the El Teatro de Sengano del Pueblo, which Philip Brandt George, particularly mentioned in one of his articles, whether it's still around.
Julie Stout: And he wrote something somewhere, the ghost… Philip Brandt George, the ghost of… Klein Avenue.
Julie Stout: the Lorona… with the… in the Calumet region. There were a few student articles. Indiana Folklore, number 6.
Julie Stout: Apparently, 1972.
Julie Stout: So he must have been up there before, why would that…
Julie Stout: And Dawson also had something, Dawson, Team Fieldwork in Northwest Indiana, in Fabula, F-A-B-U-L-A, Volume 20. I don't know anything about that article.
Julie Stout: And then John Hase with this Reverend Roosevelt Rob Robinson. I would imagine that he's well known in that church. It was a Methodist church, and it's in the book, I think, where it is.
Julie Stout: This… I've written down, open door of God Church.
Julie Stout: I don't know, because he was also part of a Baptist church, and then he went to a Methodist church.
Julie Stout: So, those… I think that if you talk to someone asked about someone, about him.
Julie Stout: they would know, and we'd feel connected. Gospel.
Julie Stout: And then…
Julie Stout: he also worked with, John Hassay worked with the Open Door Church, which was a gospel church with an elder
Julie Stout: McBennett.
Julie Stout: But, so, in other words, you can get names in… in this…
Julie Stout: One book here where the students are writing.
Julie Stout: Something about a gospel choir that does doo-wop.
Julie Stout: WWCA Radio, Gary.
Julie Stout: Yeah, it's not much, not much that I wrote down, so… It's just stuff that came to mind when you were reading it. Yeah. Anyway, there are ways… there are other… I mean, you said you wanted to go up and see if you could find somebody to talk to, and there might be some people that you could work…
Julie Stout: whose names you could work with. Yes, yes. And find them.
Julie Stout: Do some sleuthing.
Julie Stout: That was the end of my Richard Dawson section. Is there anything else you'd like to add before closing it out? Okay. I think we've covered things well enough, yeah. Thank you so much for speaking with me again, and yeah, thank you.
Julie Stout: That's good. Thank you.